i'm assuming you've had a lot of people
try to sign you
um what has been the closest you've been
assigning to a major situation um
not close at all you know not close at
all i don't think i've ever
seriously considered it yeah and i've
never seriously considered it like i
think somebody offered me something and
i definitely i completely just like
they offered me something so ridiculous
that i just sent them back something
even more ridiculous and that like the
deal was like so bad it was so bad the
deal was so bad that i felt like i was
insulted i just sent something
crazy or the other way like here's the
counter i mean
i need 25 million dollars
100 of my masters for one album i think
i asked for like i think i asked for
like a million
five hundred thousand non-recuperable
like oh yeah
like some crazy come some crazy like i
have control over all my albums and i
was like oh yeah by the way um only one
album you only get one hour yo it's
rough cause like you'll talk to some of
these like record people especially like
i i won't call them like majors but like
in between major guys
and they'll tell you like
like they'll talk to you and they'll
like tell you exactly what you want to
hear
and he'd be like oh [ __ ]
yeah that felt good and then the [ __ ]
contract gets sent over and it's always
some [ __ ] [ __ ] like every single
time like it's like you gotta almost
like if you're like an artist and you
kind of want to kind of be in your space
and like you just got to find a dope
distro partner
and turn up yeah i say the thing is with
me i i never really wanted to be rich
off this stuff you know what i mean so
it was like the minute that i saw eight
thousand dollars in my account from rap
i was like oh [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
you know what i mean so like
signing was never a problem in a month
was that a monthly check nah that was
that was just like i just saw eight
thousand in my account
it was a lot for somebody who never made
it distro kit or tunecore or something
um tunecore
and um yeah so as soon as i saw that i
was like yeah we gonna we we can do this
let's just keep on creating content so
we could keep the streams going so we
could so ever since then it was being
run like a business it was like yo how
much if we make five thousand this month
how can we make ten thousand next month
if you make you know this then how can
we make twenty thousand and
like we just worked it like that and
like it worked out